hello and welcome to this video this is
Wow
Jean is so cheese Janice Cochise yeah I
go to e3 against c5 yeah it's very very
solid and sound of course but I still
wonder what what's wrong with jeeve life
again let's just develop him now III
before it's a pretty sound way of
playing this is a basically reversed red
team the new black should equalize
fairly comfortably but why does
certainly okay now I can take a c5 next
move now I think I have to him before he
plays Knight b3 or anything but he
didn't play three before maybe he still
planned some to do that of course he can
go he for that makes it it looks a lot
like a Sicilian man the Sicilian pawn
structure the difference is that White's
pieces are not very active but here's an
easy way to develop of course okay c3
yeah I'm playing with the fianchetto of
the bishop here there were some other
options but I think doublethink arrow
here so it's looking quite fine okay I
don't need to allow a knight to be five
knight on d4 is unstable anyway I'm
ready to play e5 and d5 and then I think
white has to fight for equality in some
cases
okay 95 this is basically giving me the
bishop pair this move let's do it right
if it moves the bishop tries to keep it
why can I not take you for what is the
problem is there some tactic what if I
cannot take this I'm kind of intrigued
here I think you can do it why not I
mean yeah I can take g5 amongst others
and I can take c3 then it seven hangs
though okay um and if I take this night
Jiggs
c3 is hanging at the end that takes c3
now then there's Queenie 7 this is
indeed not over the clear okay I'll take
this and now think about this for a
moment he will take on g5 I guess
otherwise it makes no sense at all
and now if I play 97 Queenie 7 queen is
seven Bishop f6 Queen III just about
works ok I can go if I hear not sure
what was best year and not is it the
same maybe he has night a five year some
desperado move
okay I can go 96 maybe that's not so
clear probably I should have played 97
instead okay not relevant anymore that
almost certainly wasn't the best Here I
am I mean this looks all good but it's
not super convincing
that should win some material one move
earlier the bishop was still hanging
the option to Primos that's one of the
very few things that can happen here to
to screw it up play a silly pre move
check
and stalemates of course white resides
okay yeah I'm not not so happy there I
think that that should have been clearer
after after he blundered you for but
somehow it wasn't on that all that
convincing yeah yeah I think like it's
really comfortable already I always have
this idea to play e5 and d5 and in fact
i think ii v one move earlier probably
was interesting you have played this and
and then here play for d5 it's pretty
comfortable it's a very good Sicilian
structure but okay this one and now
Knights a five net Smith the bishop pair
this is why I went for it but you should
probably take a six this is just this is
just the Fed Center phone okay II five
immediately maybe that was stronger
indeed or take on c3 here what's that
bad my five is given his best Jam I mean
I'm not sure this is this is also
interesting if he takes I was thinking
this but he just has this and I mean
this is nice but not not like a win and
I really was looking for wins but okay
e5 probably wasn't all that bad then
Queens is six I am hmm but that should
also be pretty okay yeah okay
yeah I'm winning antique taking taking
was easier or better I mean yeah it's
opponent the bishop ham I mean he can
still fight because he's got active
pieces but it's certainly good for
banking yeah him
it was just winning huge chunks of
material okay guys thanks for watching